foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I got a really
um you know it was a beautiful email
from Brian Cranston when he realized
that I'd signed a contract extension and
he sent me an email and it reads
congrats on the extension glad to know
that I'll be able to tune in for the
foreseeable future of course I won't
tune in but it's just nice knowing that
I could cheers Brian Cranston the great
actor joins us now that was wonderful
Brian I'm really uh I applaud and thank
you for taking time out of your busy day
oh my you had to read that quote huh a
little a little jest a little a little
humor in the morning okay all right yeah
um
I'm good I'm good but uh I saw you out
at the uh Screen Actors Guild uh you
know that you guys are on the picket
line and I thought it'd be great to just
kind of summarize what are the main
points that the everybody is is striking
for or about in Hollywood
well there are several that we have uh
significant
um distance between uh the the actors
and the amtpp which is the The Producers
uh Guild so what we're what we're
looking at mostly is of course
wage increases uh this week the New York
Times just put out an article about
how much rent in Los Angeles have gone
up since the year 2000 35 on average and
yet wages have gone up only six percent
so it is it doesn't take a mathematician
to realize it's un untenable to to go at
that pace so yes we we do need to catch
up with with our wages for the rank and
file workers
um on on a broader more macro uh point
of view we're looking at AI with
with that
really problematic scenario
you know we've we've dealt with AI in
many cases at the grocery store you have
self check out and things like that
um uh ATMs when when you and I were
young if you needed cash you had to go
into a bank and get a cat so there are
there are definite benefits that have
come with AI sure
but when it takes uh the place of human
beings in in creating actual product
in my likeness and my voice uh in in
constructing a a story a screenplay a
play then your your usurping the
humanity of it all uh you're you're
you're taking away the intellectual
property that is actually created by
these people so they're they're
significant and they're problematic but
they're not unsurmountable we can come
to the table and and make this happen
um our our leadership at sag after has
presented that as
um a willingness from our part to meet
with them at any time
and they basically have said that they
felt us going on strike was an
aggressive and unreasonable action and
we had to you know remind them that
that's not it's a right of every
American worker to be able to stand up
for themselves
how is this going to affect content over
the next
couple of years
it's going to affect it greatly
um there
in a process of using up their content
now and there'll be a backlog so as of
right now there is there are no
Productions uh going on unless you've
received a waiver from sag after that
says you are
clearly an independent operator you're
not working under the Aegis of any
Studio or network and so we have granted
those Productions waivers to be able to
work because we want to get back to work
so there are right now over 40 different
Productions that have applied and have
received waivers to go work so not only
the actors but our our brothers and
sisters and the teamsters in iatse and
the wga are able to then
um you know get back to work how bad
could this get
well it's pretty bad right now if I'm
honest and there's been a lot of rancor
and and name calling and and that sort
of thing and I'm my whole goal is to try
to get away from that so when we were
out there this Tuesday uh in Times
Square I noticed that that our
our group was gathered uh thousands and
thousands of us in front of um Good
Morning America which is ABC which is
Disney which is Bob Iger and I wanted to
present some thoughts to to Mr Iger and
that's why I addressed him that way that
I I don't villainize him or any of the
people that we've worked with over the
years they have a different point of
view and they look through this issue
through a different lens than we do and
I I want us to see if we can all
understand that and accept that part of
it and get back to the negotiating I get
residual checks from my Adam Sandler
movies and sometimes it costs more to
send the check to my house than the
actual amount I think I've gotten 13
cents before so it cost more to send
that to me but I invested it well that
13 cents very good yeah are you saying
that 13 cents equates to the value of
your talent on those voters yes
absolutely Sandler Sandler reminds me of
that
um if you have a line in a show
uh who owns that line that you've said
uh well it's interesting uh and um I'm
not able to to talk about any of of my
personal work but when when an actor
okay hypothetical yeah when an actor
quotes a line it's written by a wga
member but it is basically owned by the
studio that that pays the bills okay
yeah
I'm going to Ireland at the end of
August
and I don't know if you have some free
time
Will Ferrell is going to join us Notre
Dame Navy football game
so I'm going to put that out there since
you've been you know behind me and and
you know so emotional with you know and
then it's an unscripted show obviously
when what you're going at the end of
August yeah
yeah you know you know my people come
from Ireland as well and uh up in the in
a county called Arma and it's up north
during the troubles it was troubling
because my my ancestors were Irish
Catholic but in a in a very Protestant
Northern Ireland area and um I've heard
a plethora of stories that are awfully
disturbing but it is a gorgeous gorgeous
country is that a yes I I mean there was
there was you shook me off there
no I didn't I I was you didn't answer
looking I didn't I didn't answer I I
mean I'm playing a little hard to get I
I don't a girl just doesn't say yes Dad
well Will Ferrell did
well he you know what kind of girl he is
very easy very very loose yes
are you wrecking are you allowed to talk
about being recognized if you go
overseas
yeah where do you get recognized or how
do people recognize you when you're
overseas
usually it's my kind of Adonis physique
of course they recognize first
um I get you know it's definitely uh
that show that that I've done
gets the most recognition and then after
that it was that other show so you can't
talk about Walter White uh Breaking Bad
or Malcolm in the Middle but you might
be recognized for those two shows
hypothetical
that I would not say no to that no
comment no yeah okay it's crazy isn't
this crazy I know yeah I know I know um
are you happy oh Tawny is staying with
the angels
I think it's a good move
you know what we saw last year with the
Phillies getting all the way to the
World Series
and I don't think there's anybody in the
country that would say there they were a
better team than Atlanta than San Diego
then you know but they made it they did
it so the the proof is in the pudding if
you can get your team in it and then
there's two factors that are always at
at Bay and that is can you stay healthy
can't what's the what's the overall
health of your team and then the second
thing is can you get hot are you hot at
that moment for that stretch of games if
you can get hot
many things can happen
is that a Rolex you have on
is that the race so the one that they
discontinued
yeah well this is um you know exactly 41
millimeter yeah yeah
it's pretty yeah they do this is
continued that yeah they did I don't
well maybe because it doesn't keep time
oh well you were in Times Square so you
oh you bought it in Times Square okay
yeah the guy said it was real it is real
it's real fake
um all right so uh if you want to join
us in Ireland I just throw it out there
but uh if you don't I certainly
understand it and you know maybe we
could do something uh together like well
have some fun uh I already have a date
at the end of August I'm going to Maui
because at the Four Seasons now we were
opening up a Dos Hombres Cucina
it's a a pop-up restaurant at the Four
Seasons Maui dos Hombres Mezcal is the
is the theme awesome and so it has
combining Mexican food with with
Hawaiian taste it's it's really
fantastic and great Cocktails so we'll
be over there at the end of August okay
we'll have fun without you we'll have
cocktails in in Dublin with my new
favorite actor Will Ferrell it also
feels like a little bit like you know
you asked a lot of other people and and
then finally come around
no it is true that is absolutely true
absolutely true
um I asked Aaron Paul before I asked you
it's unbelievable yeah I know really
unbelievable I know I've known you much
much longer and he doesn't know anything
about sports
we met him at the Super Bowl this was
2010 or 2011 and his dad came up and he
said hey my son's in this show and we're
like yeah okay great the next thing I
know he he's he told us the idea he goes
yeah you know there's a like a a former
teacher and a chemistry teacher and then
he makes uh meth and then blah blah blah
blah blah we're like oh good luck with
that show
uh thank you Brian good to talk to you
thank you Dan appreciate it and
congratulations on the extension thank
you glad you're going to be around buddy
thank you man that's uh Brian Cranston
actor but apparently not like the Will
Ferrell level of friend to this show